d'abord je
note des positions de madame le pen qui
ne correspondent pas aux positions que
votre parti et vos parlementaires
défendent parlement européen par
parenthèse qu'il s'agisse de protéger
les ukrainiens quand ils viennent sur
notre sol comme des sanctions
additionnelles après le premier paquet
comme de l'aide à l'ukraine d'ailleurs à
laquelle vous êtes aussi opposés l'aide
financière c'est faux non c'est un fait
madame le pen c'est faux ce sont les
votes et c'est d'ailleurs ce que vous
venez de dire complètement le contraire
des positions vous avez historiquement
tenue vous avez été je pense une des
premières responsables politiques
européennes dès 2014 à reconnaître le
résultat de l'annexion de la crimée je
rappelle que
en droit international en reconnaît
rarement c'est à dire qu'on ne le fais
plus la deuxième guerre mondiale des
territoires qui sont annexés par la
force alors même que vladimir poutine
avait reconnu que les conditions de ce
référendum en crimée étaient les siennes
vous l'avez fait pourquoi ai je le dis
avec beaucoup de gravité ce soit parce
que ça pour notre pays c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle parce que vous
dépendez du pouvoir russe et que vous
dépendez de monsieur poutine parce que
quelques mois après avoir dit cela
madame le pen vous avez contracté un
prêt en 2015 auprès d'une banque russe
la first tchèque russian banque proche
du pouvoir en septembre 2014 puis vous
avez ensuite rbo ticket ce prêt auprès
d'autres acteurs tout ça est totalement
transparent connu notifié notarié qui
sont impliqués d'ailleurs ensuite dans
la guerre en syrie et donc vous ne
parlez pas à d'autres dirigeants vous
parlez à votre banquier quand vous
parlez de la russie c'est ça le problème
madame le pen alors peut-être que maxi
c'est aussi ce qui ce qui fait qu'on le
voit bien dès qu'il ya des positions
courageuses et difficiles à prendre mais
vous au niveau représentant de son là ni
vous ni vos représentants et il ça n'est
pas un hasard s'il ya cinq ans la russie
était intervenue dans la campagne ce qui
a été prouvé au me déstabiliser et si
vous avez toujours été ambigu sur le
sujet à ce que vous n'êtes pas dans une
situation de puissance à puissance que
vous ne pouvez pas défendre correctement
sur ce sujet des intérêts de la france
parce que vos intérêts sont liés à des
gens proches du pouvoir us marines le
même évidemment le pouvoir de répondre à
ce que vient de dire emmanuel macron
vous délasser du pouvoir russe vous
dépendez d'ailleurs emmanuel macron
parce que il a accès à l'intégralité des
informations des services
français c'est plus vous êtes
pertinemment que ce qu'il dit est faux
il sait pertinemment que je suis une
femme absolument et totalement libre à
et que je défends parce que je suis une
patriote et que je les démontrer toute
ma vie la france et les français
toujours en toutes circonstances
maintenant ce que vous dites est faux
plusieurs fois d'abord je vous ai
retrouvé un tweet ce que j'avais fait le
9 novembre 2014 je soutiens une ukraine
libre qu'ils ne soient soumises ni aux
états unis ni à l'union européenne ni à
la russie voilà ma position c'est la
même c'était la même en irak en 2003
c'est la même pour l'ukraine aujourd'hui
je mets des moments là non mais pardon
d'accord nous allons y venir monsieur
macron nous allons y revenir la crimée
n'a pas dû vous poser énormément de
problèmes non plus puisque vous avez
reçu monsieur poutine en grande pompe à
versailles
a ouvert en amitié madame le pen en 2017
vous avez reçu monsieur poutine à
brégançon sur votre lieu de vacances et
vous avez d'ailleurs tenu à cette
occasion exactement les propos que je
que je tiens vous avez dit à cette
occasion que la russie devait être ré
arrimé à l'europe vous avez dit qu'il
fallait faire l'europe de lisbonne à
vladivostok donc ce que vous faites
aujourd'hui je n'étais pas le contraire
mais je veux dire c'est d'être dans une
posture est ce que je dis est faux que
ça n'est pas dit que ce que je dis est
faux c'est madame c'est un enjeu des
réseaux facebook c'est sûr mais ce que
je dis est faux je ne reviens sur aucune
de mes déclarations sur la russie dans
le cadre de l' architecture de sécurité
européenne bien entendu est ce que j'ai
défendue mais j'ai parlé d'un point
précis qui touche le financement de
votre parti est ce que ce que j'ai dit
est faux madame le pen oui monsieur
macro c'est faux et c'est assez
malhonnête il faut être honnête très
bien et
de compacité obligé allez faire un prêt
à l'étranger donc vous l'avez c'est
parce que mais bien sûr mais tout le
monde le sait c'est de notoriété
publique c'est parce que aucune banque
française
n'a voulu m'accorder de près et vous
trouviez ça l'époque tellement
scandaleux que vous avez fait voter une
loi sur la banque de la démocratie vous
ne l'avez jamais mise en oeuvre pourquoi
d'ailleurs monsieur mâcon ne l'avez vous
pas fait pourquoi né pas n'êtes vous pas
aller au bout de cette banque de la
démocratie dont vous saviez que l
combler un déficit démocratique des
banques qui avaient l'air de choisir
leur parti politique ou d'ailleurs
pendant les élections le les candidats
qu'elle soutenait ou qu'elle ne
soutenait pas ses mots quand je veux
dire que je suis inscrit en 2015
monsieur macro j'avais contracté en 2015
et vous ne l'avez toujours pas remboursé
est pas un sujet de banques de la
démocratie d'autres candidats à cette
élection qui défendait des idées proches
des vôtres comme monsieur zemmour ils
n'ont pas été chercher des prêts en
hongrie où ou en russie vont ils ont
trouvé des prêts en france mais monsieur
vakoumé d'objets longs à rembourser une
romance sont sous le contrôle de la
commission nationale des comptes de
campagne et croyez moi la commission des
comptes de god de campagne est
extrêmement sévère et rigoureuse voilà
donc évident j'ai autre chose à vous
dire monsieur macro il ya des millions
de français qui dans les cinq dernières
années sont allés dans des banques
françaises pour faire des prêts pour
acheter des voitures pour faire des
emprunts pour leur maison ils ne vous
doivent rien la seule chose qu'ils
doivent serbource et leurs prêts
exactement comme moi mais comme votre
serviteur aussi madame simplement ils
vont dans comme vous l'avez dit dans des
banques françaises pour payer leur
voiture ou qui vont pas chercher
plusieurs millions dans une banque russe
liés au pouvoir qu'il ne rembourse pas
c'est ça la différence
non mais toujours de comprendre à
laisser dire non je ne peux pas laisser
dire des macros je ne peux pas vous
laisser dire qu'on ne rembourse pas nous
remboursons tous les mois rubis sur
ongle un rôle de la commission nationale
des comptes de droite je ne peux pas
vous laisser songeur pas rembourser ce
prêt c'est assez long monsieur vaqueront
oui c'est vrai nous sommes un parti
pauvres mais ce n'est pas déshonorant
mais je n'ai jamais considéré que
c'était déshonorant mais le mon problème
madame le pen vous le reconnaîtrez avec
moi c'est que ceci crée une dépendance
ok je n'ai pas d'autres dépendances que
de rembourser mon prêt monsieur mac mais
votre prêt n'a pas été contractée auprès
d'une banque lambda même en russie mais
auprès des intérêts et du pouvoir et
chacun pourra le vérifier et donc
assumer le c'est tout assumer le madame
le pen beaucoup de vos choix derrière
s'explique par cette dépendance mais ça
n'est pas je ne vous en fais pas grief
je dis simplement que d'autres candidats
défendant des idées proches des vôtres
n'ont pas fait les mêmes choix et qu'ils
ont trouvé des financements
l'un des banques françaises européennes
que vous vous avez fait un choix qui
manifestement vous ensuite contraint
dans votre position politique et qui ne
vous rend pas indépendante sur cette
question c'est un fait c'est faux je
vous le redis bourré je vous rien de
faire céder c'est faux on est tous à
vous est monté je crois que les mots
c'est les arrêts devant des bancs pour
les gens nés et j'en ai eu comme tous
nos compatriotes qui pour acheter une
maison qui pour acheter un véhicule si
vous laissez l'exemple que vous avez
pris on est plus aucun d'entre nous ne
sommes allés les chercher auprès de
banques russes et encore moins des
banques qui étaient projecteurs voir
c'est quand même assez malhonnête
messieurs macro
ne me fait pas plaisir mais c'est un
fait mais chez mâcon c'est malhonnête de
m'empêcher d'obtenir un prêt dans une
banque française et de me reprocher
après mais de partir à l'étranger vont
chercher à vous rigolez ou quoi en 2015
je vous a empêché de trouver un prêt
dans une banque française vous étiez
bien ministre de l'économie et j'étais
pâmé liste des finances l'économie a pas
les bons emmanuel mal et en plus
personne n'est jamais intervenu vous le
savez très bien emmanuel macron marine
le pen il reste une question très
importante à vous creuser les
importantes que celles là avoue baiser à
voir d'où on parlait toujours important
madame le pen mais il y à l'europe parce
qu'on a parlé alors justement si vous le
permettez c'est l'union européenne et
vite
[Musique]